[Applause]
so good to see you
good to see you too man
adam hi drew i am so happy to see you
and this show
for me i would have loved it for just
the magic mic of it all
but it really gives me all the feels
by the fact that this show is about
boosting confidence
and attacking things that are not just
about
what we reveal but what we're afraid to
reveal am i right
you could i couldn't have said it better
myself i i let's sit here and talk about
something else because you nailed it i
mean that is exactly what the show is
about um
you know we we that was the goal when we
when we began the show
uh the idea of stepping into the
unscripted space was not something i was
really that interested in but the idea
of taking the experiences that i had
doing these movies and the things that i
was able to learn through the process
and the challenges and and hopefully
being able to impart some of those
some of that wisdom if you will and and
take those lessons that i learned and
share them with these guys that wanted
to have the same experience and
hopefully change their lives which i i
think we did and that's what i'm hoping
people get from the show aside from a
good time and the sexiness and you know
all of the things that are naturally
going to draw you to going to see what
finding magic mike is all about but
there's there's that big heartfelt
surprise that's there waiting for you
too and hopefully a few lessons what a
wonderful answer really well
said
all right well you want to hit some
headlines with us
let's do it okay
okay well first up we've got a brand new
trend in men's fashion i want to get
your opinion on the wall street journal
reports that megan's aka men's leggings
well they're in and they're not just for
superheroes or wearing at the gym no
more men are stepping out with leggings
on than ever before now compared to
women's they have a lower rise with some
um some extra
padding for the meat potatoes you know i
mean
you know what i'm saying
are they like spanx for men well a
little bit but i just feel like hey but
i'm wondering would you ever wear megans
i mean i have some but i don't know that
they're megan's i never called them
leggings they're just like compression
pants they call them okay and i started
wearing them a few years ago to go to
the gym
and especially during the winter they
just kept you know the bottoms of my
legs warm and i i like them and now
apparently they become a fashion trend
well do you wear a short over them or
are you just like hey
no no no shorts over there yeah but it
looks so comfortable wearing i mean
these legs were made for meggings and
that's just what they're going to do
okay i believe yeah
i can pull it off
you don't know what i'm wearing under
this desk
[Applause]
i do see men uh with leggings and shorts
all over the place right now i'm here
for it okay so moving on apparently a
lot of couples will totally deny this
but the conversation
reports that as many as two-thirds of
adult couples use baby talk
now research shows with babies that tone
releases a
neurotransmitter to motivate infants to
learn
so what's the deal with adults doing it
experts say it signals affection when
couples create their own linguistic
landscapes in private little terms and
nicknames it actually makes them feel
more bonded so adam let's start with you
do you and your wife talk baby talk
you know we don't we don't do a lot of
baby time we have three babies so we're
baby talking all the time but not always
to each other
um i mean we sweet talk each other we're
definitely going to do it can i hear
some of it
[Music]
i just asked what you said
it's usually like a whisper in the air
i'll come up behind her when we get a
moment for something and i just i
couldn't possibly love you more it's
going to take me like that you just say
like i could possibly love you more oh
my god he just said i couldn't love you
more it's going to take me a lifetime to
like show you that i love you this much
is that what you said oh yeah yeah no
there's not enough time in the world
yeah oh my god never in my life have i
baby talk can you imagine what this
voice my baby talked to be like rossie
baby talk me baby talk you drew i can't
baby talk no it's like so annoying if
somebody if wellington came to me it was
like wassi i love woo shut up get out i
can't
i can't to grow
up but but that said
do what works for you sweetie do what
works for you and we never knew how to
run weekends
we
love you and finding magic mike is out
today on hbo max
before we wrap up our news report we
have a big show announcement
we have got our own podcast
i know it happened it's real
you can catch episodes of the drew
barrymore show podcast every weekday
listen on spotify apple podcast or
wherever you get your podcast and we'll
just bring joy
information
mumble baby talk you know
[Music]